come può un organizzazione essere
efficiente e sostenibile allo stesso
tempo partiamo da questa domanda la
sostenibilità sta entrando al primo
posto nell'agenda di tutte le
organizzazioni
ma questo posto di primaria importanza è
legato a che cosa a normative sempre più
stringenti al tentativo alla volontà di
mantenere una buona reputazione
o forse c'è una nuova consapevolezza da
parte delle organizzazioni
io mi occupo ogni giorno di accompagnare
le organizzazioni nel loro cammino nel
loro percorso di trasformazione digitale
e questo percorso non può prescindere
dal tema della sostenibilità
sostenibilità ambientale sicuramente
sociale ma anche sostenibilità proprio
per l'organizzazione per le persone che
lavorano all'interno dell'organizzazione
per molto tempo l'impegno sociale ed
etico delle organizzazioni è stato
lasciato alla libertà alla libera
iniziativa
di imprenditori e manager ma mancavano
strumenti per la valutazione oggettiva e
misurabile di quelli che sono i
risultati effettivamente ai risultati di
business di un percorso nella
sostenibilità ma oggi ci si è resi conto
effettivamente che è urgente un cambio
di prospettiva
appunto perché le condizioni stanno
cambiando ma anche per ottenere dei
risultati di business
sempre di più oggi le organizzazioni
attraverso gli imprenditori e manager
capiscono l'importanza di puntare sulla
sostenibilità per ottenere vantaggi
concreti e misurabili
le aziende devono
cercare un approccio che tenga conto
dell'impatto dei loro processi e dei
loro prodotti
sul contesto sull'ambiente e questo per
un duplice obiettivo
perché
chiaro è semplice da capire perché fa
bene all'ambiente fa bene ai contesti
familiari comunità ma soprattutto anche
fa bene alle aziende dalle aziende
resilienza dalle aziende capacità di
resistere e prosperare nel lungo termine
l'introduzione dei criteri e sg
environmental social and governance ha
permesso per la prima volta di misurare
di quantificare di poter riportare in
maniera oggettiva
l'impatto delle organizzazioni in
termini ambientali sociali e di
governance
e questo al di là della natura tecnica
degli sg ha consentito di cambiare
prospettiva quindi di passare da un
concetto di singola materialità a un
concetto di doppia materialità quindi la
sigla mar materialità con una lente
unica attraverso la quale analizzare le
prestazioni di un'organizzazione la
doppia materialità invece come un
concetto più evoluto cosa significa
quindi parliamo di doppia materialità
mai significa che l'organizzazione
chiaramente è si muove all'interno di
una di un ambiente di un contesto
all'interno di una comunità e c'è una
relazione bidirezionale quindi
l'organizzazione
impatta attraverso le proprie azioni e
le proprie decisioni
sull'ambiente sulle persone e sulle
comunità e parliamo quindi di una
materialità d'impatto quindi
l'organizzazione verso l'ambiente ma c'è
anche chiaramente la freccia in
direzione opposta quindi l'ambiente le
comunità i cambiamenti climatici
i rischi di questa evoluzione
costante hanno un impatto chiaramente
sul
performance
finanziarie
dell'organizzazione e quindi parliamo di
una materialità
finanziaria in questo caso
la materialità finanziaria quindi che
impatta sull'azienda
richiede di ripensare i modelli di
business e quindi richiede di alimentare
il circolo dell'innovazione la
materialità di impatto invece quindi
ricordiamoci quella che dall'azienda va
verso il contesto verso l'ambiente
impone di pensare all'efficienza impone
di capire che le risorse sono sempre più
scarse e vanno giustamente
gestite con con equilibrio ecco che
quindi è necessario alimentare
contemporaneamente anche il motore
dell'efficienza e questo doppio motore
ci riporta alla lamenta un concetto
un concetto caro agli studiosi di
organizzazione del concetto
dell'organizzazzione ambidestra quindi
tutte le aziende hanno due motori
diversi motori dell'innovazione e il
motore dell'efficienza che sono molto
diversi appunto per attori che li
presidiano per processi per metri che
utilizzate per valutare i risultati però
entrambi i motori sono importanti e
devono muoversi in maniera sinergica per
consentire l'evoluzione delle
organizzazione e soprattutto in contesti
evolutivi come quelli che stiamo che
stiamo vivendo
un esempio sono ad esempio un'azienda
del caffè e quindi potrei possa
ricercare nuovi materiali ad esempio noi
materiali compostabili per per
realizzare le capsule di caffè quindi
possa ricercare l'innovazione ma posso
anche attraverso ad esempio delle
partnership posso
cercare nuove strade
magari così innovativa quindi più legate
a piccoli miglioramenti
ad esempio nel progetto alle cup fvg
della regione friuli venezia giulia due
importanti aziende leader di caffè la
regione stessa e tra le aziende che
gestiscono i rifiuti urbani in regione
stanno testando un impianto sperimentale
per separare il contenitore del caffè al
contenuto dal caffè per il successivo
recupero dei materiali
quindi innovazione da una parte magari
che guarda al lungo termine e dall'altra
parte azioni se vogliamo anche più
limitate più veloce nel tempo che però
possono portare risultati immediati ma
come avviare un percorso di
miglioramento un percorso diventata la
sostenibilità come avviarlo e come
sostenerlo abbiamo detto che ci sono
delle metodologie oggi ci sono degli
strumenti ci sono delle metriche
e quindi è il momento di farlo e come
beh diciamo attraverso due step
principali il primo step è quello della
valutazione del contesto della
misurazione del contesto dell'ambiente
in cui un'organizzazione chiamata ad
operare
che tipo di complessità
un'organizzazione è chiamata a gestire
la complessità strutturale una
complessità delle relazioni una
complessità emergente che
appunto tiene in considerazione tutte le
dinamiche in atto
è possibile quantificare e qualificare
la materialità finanziaria e la
materialità di impatto di cui parlavamo
prima ecco questi elementi sono degli
elementi su cui l'organizzazione a poco
controllo e dipendono dal contesto
dipendono dalla
scelta anche del modello di business del
posizionamento ma è fondamentale
comprendere le fondamentale comprendere
qual è appunto la complessità del
contesto in cui l'organizzazione opa
ecco il primo step il secondo invece
secondo è quello che ci dà le carte che
possiamo giocarci come azienda perché ci
dà le leve su cui possiamo agire secondo
step quindi è l'analisi del livello di
sviluppo di che cosa di tre dimensioni
fondamentali i processi le tecnologie e
l'organizzazione
sempre nell'ottica della sostenibilità
ambientale sociale e della governance
questo ci permette di capire qual è il
gap tra il contesto è il livello di
sviluppo dei propri processi tecnologie
e organizzazione quindi consente di
definire delle priorità e di progettare
delle road map di implementazione basate
su dati
strutturati anche qua un esempio reale
un'azienda del settore tessile
in cui questa metodologia è stata
applicata primo step analisi del
contesto ci dà un risultato di un
contesto complesso di una materialità
alta un indice dell 85 per cento
dall'altra parte secondo step un livello
di sviluppo del 50 per cento circa
quindi sicuramente c'è un gap da colmare
in quali aree nel caso specifico di cui
stanno parlando
sui processi di sviluppo prodotto e di
tracciabilità e di certificazione del
prodotto ecco che l'azienda a fronte di
questa consapevolezza di questa analisi
ha avviato un percorso di
reingegnerizzazione dei processi e di
trasformazione digitale che le
consentono oggi di avere dei processi di
sviluppo prodotto
digitalizzati integrati con i propri
partner
principali fornitori chiave e processi
che a questo punto consentono loro di
raccogliere costantemente dati che vanno
ad alimentare il ciclo del miglioramento
continuo
ecco che in definitiva si può fare la
mia esperienza quotidiana mi dice che si
può fare
oggi ci sono gli strumenti ci sono le
metodologie
ci sono i dati di cui abbiamo bisogno
perché è necessario innescare questo
processo questo processo di
miglioramento continuo che avrà un
effetto l'abbiamo capito sicuramente
sull'ambiente sicuramente sui contesti
sulle persone ma anche sulla resilienza
dell'organizzazione